as it comes down to those four teams
that are still alive peter colts ravens
titans steelers which one
intrigues you the most if they get in
well to me the ravens are the most
intriguing because it was funny mike the
other day i was talking to bill parcells
just
you know about this season and
everything and it was it was the day
after
uh the ravens beat the chargers
and
one of the things he said and you sort
of forget about this remember we were
sitting here two months ago or maybe
maybe even
six weeks ago decrying the fact that
nobody played defense anymore
and i think uh parcells message was game
always comes back and i think he's right
you know i think the ravens would be a
fairly unique team
in these playoffs because think about it
mike
since lamar jackson has been starting
for them i had a stat in my column on
monday
that
lamar jackson
and and the ravens have run the ball 65
of the time since he's been the starter
and the great running teams of the 60s
the cleveland browns in 64 the packers
the super bowl packers they didn't run
the ball even 58 percent of the time
so there's some revolutionary stuff
happening in baltimore and it'd be very
interesting to see how far they could
take it
well and one of the real questions is
can lamar jackson stay healthy both in
this playoff run and beyond and that you
know there's a way the dominoes fall
where he gets injured and joe flacco has
a chance to come in and be the hero for
the baltimore ravens but between that
defense the way they're playing offense
the preparation challenge that it
creates when you're talking about the
next playoff game wild card divisional
round however far they go and they have
a history under john harbaugh of playing
well in the postseason on the road in
new england if that ends up being where
they go at some point i'd be very
concerned if i'm the new england
patriots i'd be very concerned about
facing the ravens at any juncture of the
postseason and i agree with you they're
the most intriguing team and i think
they're the most dangerous of the teams
that have yet to get in you talked
earlier about the chargers i i look it
could be
the uh the chargers at the five seed the
ravens at the four seed and those could
end up being the two most dangerous
teams in the afc playoff field because
there really isn't a team like the
saints in the afc where we say this team
is dominant and this team is destined to
to make a serious run at the super bowl
well i think the one thing about the
chargers that is really really important
for phillip rivers
look
you're not going to change the offensive
line overnight you know they they are
what they are
as i wrote monday in my column you know
pro football focus has their offensive
line against baltimore surrendering 20
pressures
by those five offensive linemen the two
tackles combined
to surrender 12
pressures on philip rivers so what's
incumbent
on this on this offense right now for
them to be good enough
to survive the leaks up front is to get
melvin gordon going and they have got to
have a semblance of a running game a
reliable semblance of a running game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports